absolutely and the individuals that have
done these actions that uh you know
whether it's dancing on on the the tomb
of the unknown soldier whether it's uh
you know putting uh flags and such on on
terry fox a very icon of this nation uh
whether it's uh you know harassing
people in any business uh in particular
uh people that might be uh working in in
a homeless shelter um these people
should be held accountable um if the
acts that they have performed are
illegal i would hope that the rcmp the
the or the opp in this case or whoever
the the law enforcement agency is um
would ultimately hold these individuals
accountable and i would go a step
further to say that
what these individuals are doing um they
owe canadians an apology it's absolutely
despicable that we see uh people doing
uh this it takes away um from the
broader uh message that the vast
majority of law-abiding folks that are
participating in in whether it be the
ottawa rally this is this rally we saw
here in regina or numerous other
communities across the province as well
it takes away from uh the the message
that they are conveying is that vaccine
mandates are not working vaccine
mandates are not necessary and there's
something they'd like the federal
government to remove
ours is very different in saskatchewan
we have the proof of negative test
option and we've signaled that we will
be ultimately
removing that in the days ahead
we've seen
these type of
actions by individuals at previous uh
you know what previous gatherings at
various times if we look back in history
and and we should always remember that
when an individual
performs a despicable act like we are
seeing here or like quite frankly when
we saw
a
number of people uh in in in front of
this building uh having their voices
heard on a very important topic we saw
one individual ultimately spray paint
over the names of soldiers that have
given their life to this country in this
province
on our war memorial here in regina also
a despicable act also uh an individual
that should ultimately be held
accountable for that act but it is in no
way
should detract from the message that was
being brought forward and heard on that
particular date and the same holds true
today
sections of the bad people but what
about the silence and indifference of
the good people um including yourself
because many are not commenting on the
actions or standing up against the
actions unless they're prompted by the
media through questions so what about
the you know silence and indifference
that we're seeing from the standardized
i would encourage anyone uh when they
see someone that's doing uh something
that is uh uh
you know discriminatory whether it is
something that ultimately is uh is uh
you know a despicable act like what we
have been uh discussing uh here today um
whether and and if it's an illegal act
they should they should step in and i
won't ascertain between good and bad
people but most certainly we should step
in and we should stop um some of the
actions that we have ultimately seen
we've all seen them on the news um but
us also as individuals and and you
ultimately as the media we should always
be separating out individual actions
from uh the you know the broader message
that people want to bring and we see a
number of those messages on various
topics that come and arrive at the front
of this building we saw a large one uh
this weekend with the what started with
truckers but i can assure you that in
addition to truckers out front of this
building this weekend there was teachers
there was nurses there was other health
care workers there was welders there was
frontline workers in our in our retail
businesses uh from across the province
and uh and that's why we communicated
with them our support for that broader
initiative and our support and and what
ultimately we are hearing from
saskatchewan people is that as we find
our way to living with covet a part of
that is going to be reducing the public
health measures that we have in place
and we're taking a very
bold but responsible
view as to when we're going to be able
to do that